- So, what do you do?
- What do I do?
- My name is Scott, and
I own a male strip club.
(hip hop music)
- Yes!
- Oh! Hi, scott.
- Hi, guys.
- So, we have a really
big live show coming up,
so we wanna do something really
memorable and incredible--
- You wanna get some pussies wet, I think.
- Exactly what I was thinking.
- Yeah, I can help you with that,
if you're willing to commit to it.
- Six, seven, eight. (whinnying)
Smack, smack, smack, smack.
- When women go out to a male strip show,
they're very open with each
other about their fantasies.
- Seriously, four dicks were
just in our face! No way!
- They expect to be entertained,
so you have to do a lot more than just
take off your clothes.
- It's more like theater.
- Exactly.
Girls don't really appreciate that as much
as they do the entire performance,
really portraying a character from A to Z
with visuals and costumes
and the theme and the look.
Hollywood Man is a collection of
the most popular female sexual fantasies
brought to life on stage.
- We have a group number
that you'll be teaching
us choreography to.
- How many weeks do you have to prepare?
- None.
- One.
- One? None? Okay, we better get started.
- Rolling, rolling that body,
rolling that body into your crotch.
- Can you show me that one again?
How do you do it?
- It's just body roll, stomp.
- You can't just say just body roll.
I need more than that.
- As long as you don't mind
me being brutally honest.
I'm not gonna waste your
time. Don't waste mine.
- I don't promise that we won't waste
a little bit of your time.
(whinnying)
- 'Cause I'll be under the mask,
so I won't be...
I can go like...
I'm a horse, yes.
- The most important thing
would be stage presence.
If you can smile on
stage and carry a crowd,
without necessarily having
to do it with your body.
It's tough to get out of your head
and forget your choreography
and just have the eye
contact with the crowd
and have that stage presence.
- Do we need names? Like stripper names?
- Oh, yeah. Are there stripper names?
- Hammersberger's pretty classic.
- These are ladies. Loosen them up.
Get them to laugh.
- I'm a bachelorette.
I'm about to get wed.
- You're being sexy,
and then all of a sudden you're like...
- Oh, my goodness. My friends.
- You downplay the sexiness.
- Okay, so you almost get
sexy, but then not quite.
- This is downplaying sexiness?
- [Guys] Ooooh
- No.
- So, he's like a coy little minx.
- I'm just like a...
I'm Willy Wonka.
- Anything that's not what you expect,
that's what I try to put on stage.
- Ripping off pants is hard.
What's harder than that?
Ripping off a straight jacket.
- Nasty Ned. I went to
a mental institution
'cause I just had boners all the time.
- Velcro goes down the side.
- It's like when you're about to rip
a woman's panties off.
- I'm dialed in.
I want you so bad I can't
be constrained by pants!
- Like I said, get the momentum.
- But how do I make that sexy?
- Zesty Zach?
Do you have a lemon rind
on your body or what?
- I am a defender of the universe.
- [Scott] Oh, it's a superhero.
- Star Wars. I have a light saber.
- Dude, when you've
got the button come on,
you gotta go zzzzzt.
You could just hold it here
and just look at the girls
with your eyebrows up,
and they get the point.
We use a lot of audience
members in the routines.
Grab a girl out of the
audience, lay her down.
- [Zach] And then for the great finale--
- [Scott] She strokes your light saber.
When women get in this environment
it's so electric.
It's like we're a catalyst
in a test tube of women.
You come backstage with
scratches down your back.
- I've given lap dances drunk.
(grunting)
- You gotta use a girl that's gonna
do what you want
(roars)
and not do what you don't want.
- Here it is.
- Yeah, there you go.
- Great.
- I've never had someone tell me
"This is a great lap dance move."
I'm a tiger.
- Yes.
Okay. What's coming at me?
- The hiring standards are very strict.
I'll put it that way.
- Alright, let's see what
you guys can do without us.
Let's see if you're ready.
- And remember, be sexy.
- Be sexy.
- How's it going, ladies and gentlemen?
- Thank you all for coming out tonight.
- [Announcer] Welcome to BuzzFeed live.
We said things were gonna get weird,
and they're about to get a lot weirder.
- So, this is it. We're here.
It's the night of the live show.
Apparently there is a
line around the block.
- I'm so nervous!
- Yeah, I'm terrified.
- It's really uncomfortable
putting yourself out there like this.
- We've never performed anything like this
in front of strangers.
- [Zach] I just did the tech run through.
- [Eugene] A lot of stuff went wrong.
- [Zach] When I did the rehearsal
the pants didn't fully rip off.
- [Eugene] I focused
so much on choreography
that when I forgot something
I just got mad, and I stopped.
- You know what, though?
I feel good.
I have a lot of nervous energy right now.
- [Eugene] Why don't you just relax,
hump some girl face--
- [Keith] And I got to do it with
the rest of The Try Guys,
and we all are bringing a
different thing to the table.
- I'm just gonna go out there
and feed off that energy of the crowd.
Alright, Keith, you ready to horse up?
(snorting)
- [Keith] Hopefully we'll
make the Hollywood Men proud.
- [Announcer] BuzzFeed's fab four
of phallic filth,
The Try Guys!
(screaming and cheering)
(“Pony” by Ginuwine)
- It was deafening.
You could barely hear the
music you were dancing to.
For me it was crazy,
'cause I didn't see the audience
until I took my horse mask off,
and by then there was just
a sea of cell phone cameras.
It was like I was Miley Cyrus!
I stuffed my thong with Sweet'N Low
and just showered it
all over the audience.
The Sweet'N Low is flying.
People were screaming.
I thrusted with my dick,
that way and that way.
This is the greatest day of my life.
- [Ned] The crowd was so energetic.
They were so into it,
and I just fed off of that,
and unleashed my inner freak show.
It was amazing.
I teased them slowly, and then...
The one move that mattered to me I nailed,
and that was the greatest
feeling in the world.
("Crazy in Love" by Beyonce)
- Oh, man. Oh, man!
That was the most fun I've ever had.
I just felt totally in control.
The thrill of ripping your underwear off
in front of over 100 people,
oh my God, it's the biggest
thrill I've ever had in my life.
- I do wish you had chosen
someone other than my girlfriend
to dance on.
("Hero" by Enrique Iglesias)
She had a great time.
She was showering money on you!
(grumbles)
- Once I got out of my own head
and got more into my pelvis,
things worked beautifully.
You know what, it all just washed away.
I just performed, and I
connected with the audience,
and I lap danced the
shit out of Ned's wife.
- The pinnacle of rude things
you could do to a person.
- I gave her a good lap dance.
- I wanna do it again. I
would do this all the time.
- I think the key to life now is
you just gotta strip sometimes.
- That's the secret.
Just take off our clothes,
everybody loves you!
- But it's more about
putting on a great show,
and we put on a pretty good show.
♫ Save a horse, ride a cowboy ♫
- [Announcer] Give it up for The Try Guys,
ladies and gentlemen.
Give it up.
- Honestly, we're just the
luckiest guys in the world
that we get to get naked in
front of complete strangers,
and they scream, but in a good way.